et avant même la multiplication des
tests voulue par le gouvernement les
initiatives locales pour lutter contre
la propagation du virus se multiplie
illustration dans la banlieue lyonnaise
ou en drive-in de dépistage vient d'être
installé reportage luis carvalho et
alexis kong
alors qu avez-vous eu comme symptôme que
un système de dépistage du coc vide 19
sur le parking d'un espace culturel
voilà le dernier dispositif lancé par la
commune de saint priest dans la banlieue
lyonnaise à la demande du laboratoire
médical de la ville du lundi au vendredi
entre 11 heures et midi hervé itri
biologiste et posté sur ce parking mis à
disposition par la mairie en attendant
ces patients un dispositif qui permet de
dépister de 10 à 15 personnes par jour à
l'origine nous avons été contactés par
les laboratoires d'analysés médicales de
la ville de saint priest assez
rapidement on a trouvé une
une possibilité qui était de faire un
drive à l'intérieur d'un équipement de
la ville et donc en fonction du cahier
des charges que le labo des laboratoires
nous ont donné on a installé l'ensemble
de l'équipement en mettant comme vous
pouvez le voir des sens de circulation
tracé au sol peut-être manière à ce que
les voitures ne se croisent pas et puis
ensuite du matériel de telle manière à
ce que les voitures puissent rentrer à
l'abri pour le test
et puis des équipements pour les
personnels soignants à tour de rôle à
pied ou en voiture les personnes munies
d'une ordonnance médicale peuvent donc
se faire tester et si vous êtes en
voiture nul besoin de décembre le
prélèvement nasal ne dure que quelques
secondes que tesla est un test
virologique sert à savoir si au niveau
des fautes nasale on a le virus ou pas
l'employeur peut demander pour le retour
au travail dont ils le font parce qu'il
faut le faire il ya des gens qui sont en
contact avec des personnes âgées et
cetera qui ont peur d affecter dons qui
seront testés il ya des gens qui ont des
symptômes ou qui ont en ce moment donc
ils veulent savoir pour protéger les
autres donc il ya de tout dans la
graduation il ya des gens qui sont
absolument pas inquiet il ya des gens
qui sont très très inquiets les
échantillons sont ensuite envoyés au
laboratoire médical qui pilote ce projet
pour y être analysé les résultats sont
quant à eux communiquée dans les jours
suivants c'est le deuxième drive de ce
type dans la région rhône alpes